so supplemental winter feeding uh with
uh primarily with hay um one of the
things that we do is um it's a lot
easier to feed hay this time of year
september
october early november because we're not
as wet
so in the barn behind me over here are
our fall cows
and so they're they're actively calving
at this point in time and so we've
brought them off of our pastures and
we're feeding them hay right now
and letting our pastures regrow so that
we can stockpile that grass
and then once it gets a frost on it it
increases the sugar content so whenever
these cows are done calving
and the first of november
we're going to kick them back out of
this of this area and they're going to
go back out on the fescue pastures which
have been stockpiled they've had a frost
on them the sugar content is almost
through the roof
and so they're going to have better
nutrition on those fields then when it's
wet and it's harder to feed hay in a
conservation friendly way
so we're feeding the hay here in the
barn on concrete we're collecting that
manure we're distributing that manure
where it needs to go
primarily back on hay fields where the
hay came from originally
and then in the winter time we're not
out rutting our fields up by packing hay
out into the fields uh we do
always have to feed some hay out in the
fields
and when we do that we use hay rings
or we also use uh unrolling so we'll
unroll the hay out on the pasture
and it depends upon the scenario if it's
really soupy and wet
if you unroll the hay in our experience
you're going to have a tremendous amount
of waste
and you want to unroll hay basically you
want to give them one day's allotment at
a time if the ground is not frozen
um
and so if the ground is not frozen and
it's really wet and soupy then you've
got to pack hay out every single day
to keep it to where you're not losing a
bunch of hay
so when is when conditions are like that
uh we hope to be grazing stockpile uh
but if we're not able to graze stock
power for whatever reason then we're
going to feed hay in rings
and so then we can feed maybe a week's
amount of hay on one day we can get out
there while the ground is frozen early
one morning or something
but if conditions are right we really
like to unroll hay because it spreads
those nutrients out in those pastures so
much more effectively and i think we get
when the conditions are right
we get much better utilization of the
hay and less waste